going to begin with this you'll be very
interested in this as a new mom
the u.s is one of the world's only
developed countries that does not
guarantee
paid family leave think about that for
just a second nearly one in four mothers
in this country
returns to work within two weeks of
giving birth president biden's paid
leave proposal in the american family's
plan would provide
12 weeks of paid leave to workers caring
for a new children
or a sick family member tech
entrepreneur alexis ohanian is a long
time advocate for paid family leave
ohanian is founder of the investment
fund 776
he's a co-founder of reddit and of
course he's a husband of tennis star
serena williams
and best of all he's a father of
three-year-old olympia one of the cutest
little girls in the world
alexis hey it's so good to see you again
good to be back i know this issue hits
very close to home because
i remember reading a story that you
wrote that when you were born and you're
an only child
your dad took off one day from work just
one
and when olympia was born how much time
did you take off from work
i took my full leave you know 12 weeks
and
and at the time i wanted to set an
example as a leader of my company and a
leader in the tech industry i wanted to
role model
the kind of behavior i wanted my
employees uh to
follow especially men um and
you know i was grateful um to have that
responsibility or have that opportunity
and that responsibility
because it was you know a very
complicated child birth for my wife
yes we remember reading about documented
yes but you know the thing that's
interesting alexis
you hadn't even thought about this issue
until you had your own child
i know sad but true um you know credit
to our
vp of people and culture caitlyn
holloway she was the one who had brought
the proposal the plan
to the company and you know i was i was
really just checking a box because it
seemed like this was something we would
just need to have in order to get the
best
and the brightest to come work for us um
but it wasn't until it really
deeply and personally affected me that i
realized this is something that
every american deserves to have uh and
and feel confident to take advantage of
and i'm
thrilled to see what president biden has
laid down here
i agree with you luckily you got to
spend so much time with olympia
what are some of the priceless
milestones that you feel like you got to
see if you and because you were there
i mean i you know just spending the time
that i got to spend early on
i had never grown up around babies so
changing diapers
doing all these things were were pivotal
and it was it was important you know
serena was coming out of
a number of surgeries and those
responsibilities just sort of naturally
fell on papa and just getting that time
even
even the slightly loopy late nights
trying to to sort of calm her back to
sleep
were moments that i'm grateful i got to
spend because i think they laid a
foundation
for for me to know look there's a lot of
stuff you just learn on the fly as a
parent
and going through that period and having
the time to just learn on the go and
improvise and actually
feel like it's going to work out gave me
the confidence to know no matter what
i can be there for her i can figure it
out we'll get through it
and i'm grateful for it and every dad
deserves it just like every mom yeah
alexis says it's anthony as much as it's
the right thing to do
it sure seems like you also say it's
actually good for the economy
explain that yes look i'm coming at this
as a business leader
i'm saying this is vital because i want
my employees to be
working when they're at work i want them
to be their whole selves i want them to
be focused
and if you have a newborn certainly if
you have a situation with complications
or extra stress
you're not going to be your best self at
work and the idea that this is a country
that
believes in families is the bedrock
which i believe it does
but also as a country where one in four
american women is back to work
10 days after giving birth i can't
reconcile those things
and i want to know it's possible for
everyone because i know it's better for
the health outcomes of
the the mother of the children and that
means cost reduction
that means cost savings that means more
prosperity for all of us
and uh and i think it's actually on the
horizon now and as an employer i'm
excited because i want this to be
something that's not just a privilege
for the few to be able to take but
something for every american yeah i
agree with you you sent a very powerful
message
last year when you resigned from your
board of directors and you you said
you want to give your seat to a person
of color what role did fatherhood play
in that decision at the time because at
the time people thought whoa
you could have just added another seat
to your board you could have done that
well you know it was it was thinking
about a future conversation i'd have
with olympia
and knowing that she's going to grow up
with
a a very different very different
uh situation uh than i did and
as a father of a daughter especially a
black daughter
i wanted to make sure i'd have really
good answers for her about decisions i
made in my career and my work
and one of the things i realized even in
that active resignation was
it was a forcing function to bring
change not just
to be replaced by a black director but
also to finally ban
you know a number of hate communities on
the platform and so that was
you know it was it was motivating for me
because so much of what i've tried to do
especially in the last year since
is set an example and do the kind of
work that i hope when
you know she's a snarky teenager she can
look back on and say all right you know
what
my father used the platform he had he
used the privilege he had to
to make things better for me and a lot
of people like me yeah you have a lot
going on
you also have a podcast called business
dad
wow um and you also you're talking to
high profile dads about business and
balance that work life
what have you learned from those fathers
you know
um one of my favorite guests was hassan
minaj
and and one of the things he talked
about you know his wife called him out
specifically for this early on and said
take this time with your daughter take
this time to be with her
because you will never get it back and
and that will be something you'll look
back
on uh as a regret and and he he you know
he's also a hard working
you know uh uh pretty motivated uh
career-driven talented young man
now alexis you've been called up by your
wife too which which i also
i rather enjoy i remember serena well i
remember
serena serena said to you you work
harder than i do and you said thank you
so much she said
that is not a compliment that's such a
good way to put it because she works
very hard she goes that's not a
compliment
dude that you work harder than i do what
message was she saying to you
what she hit on the head was the fact
that i had a kind of warped view
of of the path to excellence and the
path to greatness being a direct result
of just pure
work and that is obviously core to it
but
one thing that i'm still working on is
is balancing that with time off with
time away with time to reset and
recharge
and something she's really good at is
shutting it off and focusing on
family time or personal time and and you
know i'm always a smartphone away
from dipping back into a term sheet or
dipping back into work and
yeah i certainly uh certainly still get
checked from time to time on that one
because it's
it's something that i i want to be my
best i think we all do and that was
i think one of the motivations behind
even starting business dad
we need more men talking about this
stuff exactly because
i mean so many career-driven men who
also
as soon as you get them talking about
their kids you realize they care as much
about this they care more about this
exactly alexis ohanian alexis ohanian
we've been debating how do you say your
last name
i
okay alexis thank you very much we
appreciate it thank you so much